how do you make sense of
the holocaust
that
of nazi germany that such things could
be committed by human beings to each
other
is it religion
is it
the thirst for power is it the madness
of crowds somehow carrying
us forward
i i mean for me it's multicausal
i don't think there's one reason so one
of the things especially there has to do
with the special nature of anti-semitism
which is let's put that to one side for
the moment
the second is i think human beings are
fundamentally split
they are mostly good except when put
under certain pressures
my first explanation for hatreds is as
follows
go to a playground
what happens when a new kid comes on the
playground do the other kids say oh
let's go share our toys with the new kid
no they say uh who's that stranger and
let's go get him
because otherness is built into our
genetic i mean we're tribal by nature
and we see people form tribes all the
time of different kinds
i asked you before if you were a chess
player
and
when i was a kid and playing in
tournaments and i didn't do it for that
long and i didn't do it that well but
when i was it was like the whole world
was divided into people who could play
chess and people who couldn't play chess
which is ridiculous if you think about
it as though that's the way you divide
the world but we
we tend to do that and the jews were
always the identifiable other there were
frenchmen and jews there were russians
and jews there were germans and jews and
the great blessing of america is that
there's no identifiable other
quite that way is that there's all these
minorities and no
there's not an american and a something
um
but once you have that identifiable
other and you have a long history of
blaming that identifiable other for all
the ills that befall you of course
people still do try to form you said
america they still try to form other i
mean immigrant versus uh
been here for a generation there's so
many ways to slice it we still try to
find ways it's just more difficult in
america because there's so many
sub-tribes hierarchies of tribes upon
trial absolutely right and i was moving
fast because i didn't want to get bogged
down in all the very difficult
it's true i tried
you're hoping i wouldn't mention that
tribalism happens in america skating you
know some
when you're on thin ice your safety is
in your speed um so i was trying to move
fast yeah but for most of history in in
eastern western europe not obviously in
the in asia but in eastern western
europe jews were the ones who like
they're not like us
they're clearly not like us
um and so
and in addition there was there's a
peculiar quality and i don't know i
wonder what you'll think of this
explanation there's a peculiar quality
to anti-semitism that is unlike any
other hatred that i know of which is
jews are both superhuman and subhuman
they're vermin the nazis thought of them
as vermin and yet they control the world
and
there was an english scholar named hyman
maccabee who said the reason that that's
so is the myth that jews killed
god
they killed jesus and to kill a god you
have to be super humanly evil you can't
just be bad otherwise you can't kill a
god so there is some like supercharged
evil sense
that people got from that about jews
that still in here's
yeah that's true a lot of the way we
formulate the other in terms of tribes
is often
they're sub-human and they're here to
steal our resources like on the
playground
and but to be both
is a fascinating construction
you